the jurogan experience you know coming
back to food food intelligence
uh china right now is hoarding grain
they they supply 60 of the world's grain
they've been hoarding it for a while
actually maybe a year and a half two
years so we're gonna have a shortage a
global shortage the the meat processors
they're not interested in
really using livestock anymore it's just
a lot more profitable
and we're training people you know oh
now it's an amazing thing and you know
um
uh
is it burger king or um someone just
came out with you know new soy mcnugget
nuggets
um you know we're being kind of pushed
into this and all we know is we put it
in our face it has the same texture it
tastes the right way
and um
and the profits are much better so
that's where people are starting to
reach out and say well you know why
don't i go go meet a rancher one day and
you know and uh and a local processor
it's not usda they can't get that but in
texas you're allowed to sell you know
your meat directly uh without usda stamp
one of the few states
um vegetables all this stuff we're gonna
have to figure it out because we're
gonna have shortages i think we're gonna
have some serious food shortages it'll
be weird
like bread might not show up or
something else will happen but we're
gonna have shortages well we have a
bunch of problems right
one of the big ones is large population
centers aren't self-sustainable entirely
not yeah they they need food shipped
into them they need which is really
foods in nature it's really weird if you
think about the size of like a new york
city it's enormous right there's so many
people there's a building it's a perfect
place because the buildings are stacked
on top of each other and everything is
like like when you're there you're like
wow there's so much pretty much so much
[ __ ] energy in this place yeah but
like nothing's i mean very little is
getting grown in terms of food
very little nothing definitely not
enough to sustain it so you got to keep
shipping things in so you got to keep
the roads good because you're always
just bringing things in on boats and
bringing things in on trucks everything
has to come in i mean uh when you the
one of the cool things about like
watching a video about a really good
restaurant is seeing them going to meet
the fish as the fish are coming in off
the boats and yeah everything has to get
there yeah someone's got to deliver
something they've got to go to farmer's
market and get these big crates from
someone way the [ __ ] away who grew up we
used to have a fish market uh you know
which became very popular to live uh you
know in uh in new york it literally was
the the fish market and the [ __ ] came in
the guys were slicing [ __ ] up and moving
it out in the middle of the night it was
a dangerous place to be lots of hookers
in that neighborhood it was cool as [ __ ]
and now it's like you know three million
dollar uh one uh one-bedroom apartments
there those are hard men that fillet
fish all day
those are hard [ __ ] men it is very
hard that is a hard job that's a real
[ __ ] job and you're seeing that too
you know kids are looking around and
their parents are saying you know maybe
not go to college maybe go to vocational
school learn learn learn to trade
there's plenty of be entrepreneurial
yeah seeing a lot of that so you're
you're an optimist always always that's
good because there's a lot of people
that share your perspective that there's
some serious [ __ ] things that are
wrong and i wanted to talk about like
the grain thing first of all i did not
i've never heard the china grain thing i
only learned it recently myself
yeah it's uh it says according to data
from the u.s department of agriculture
china is expected to have 69
of the globe's maze reserves i like how
they use the native american terms
so it's like cinema it's maze it's not
corn it's so open-minded
uh
in the first half of crop year 2022 60
of its rice and 51 of its wheat yeah
here's my thing
you can keep all that [ __ ] because it's
not good for you anyway
how about that well this is another
thing
can we stop with the rapeseed oil and
canola oil already that shit's not good
for you right that is industrial sludge
brother and everyone's cooking with it
it's in everything yeah the market
because it's rapeseed oil but now we
call it canola oil the marketing has
been fantastic is a rough word to sell
health conscious folks have you had any
rape seeds well i feel like it when i've
had it yeah
it's um
there's a well-known fact that um
there's
too much
uh grain in a lot of people's diets yeah
in terms of like people that eat bread
all day and pasta and like come on like
that's not something you should have all
day like do you use animal shells for
cooking what do you use for cooking yeah
beef tallow okay because most there was
a i think a psyop basically on the
american people
like oh that's going to kill you you
can't have uh you can't use a
protein
beef protein for your fat for cooking
because they wanted it
well you just have to expect people are
asking money i use money for money
sometimes it's got a high answer is
money it's always money yeah i mean look
it's great stuff rapeseed and more and
more farmers are being incentivized in
the united states to grow
the last harvest what is it what exactly
does those processed seed oils do that's
bad to you because there's a lot of
people that are like hardcore on it like
paul saladino is very hardcore on it
rob wolf's very hardcore on it i believe
i hope i'm not misrepresenting his
position but i think a lot of those guys
think you should avoid those kind of
fats
like those kind of the those processed
seed oils here's what i know the process
is number one right i've learned this
from my buddy texas slim
and great name yes well and he kind of
came out of semi-retirement he's a
little bit young he's about
our age a little younger
um
to start the beef initiative
and so he's setting it up so people are
getting connected with you know just
basically with directly with farmers and
food and you know using bitcoin as kind
of the common network but more
importantly he's writing and educating
people
um
uh
about food
and one of the most compelling arguments
for me he said look at pictures of my
because he's a 12th generation texan or
something so look at pictures of my
great great grandparents how do they
look you know they got some shitty ass
clothes on but they look pretty good
yeah now
now go to houston how do people look now
so what's the difference people used to
live off of beef in texas
um you know it's not a great place to to
grow you know seas but we have the
original seeds the ones that aren't you
know genetically modified
the the the bee you know the the cattle
manure that fertilize the ground not
using artificial stuff you know we you
know whatever you need to to hyper grow
stuff
and we looked much better and now go to
houston everyone's obese so
you know it's got to be the intake it's
got to be the input it's not
just the sedentary well i think there's
a lot of people around here
very active a lot of people exercise a
lot of young but people aren't that
healthy looking even in austin it's not
all that great no no i don't think so
you